messmer on te laisse travailler alors tu
peux travailler rapidement en direct
alors 48 on est en direct vous allez
voir que tout ça est vrai et gilles
verdez voilà eux
alors gilles verdez est très réceptif 1
francesca et gilles vous allez place et
les deux mains dans cette position avec
les deux index qui pointent en direction
du plafond
si vous voulez l'essayer dans la salle à
fait le même mais comme ça les deux a
essayé chez eux les gens également oui
les gens les maisons peuvent le cio si
bien alors vous ouvrez les doigts vous
faites un espace un centimètre entre les
deux index a regardé l'espace entre les
doigts fixé cet espace fixé le vide
maintenant imaginez que je transpire
sous les doigts avec une vis je prends
la vis et je serre la vis
regardez vos doigts qui se colle au dos
se rapproche et 5 ont encore de mieux en
mieux
de plus en plus de plus en plus coller
de plus en plus sous des regards des
vaudois les vaudois se rapproche
maintenant encore de plus en plus fort
et de plus en plus sonné je vous tenté
de résister plus vaudois se rapprochent
et se colle j'avais compté jusqu'à 3 et
affronteront resteront coincés collet et
soudés ensemble et avec le 1-1 les
doigts colle maintenant de mieux en
mieux de plus en plus avec le 2
de plus en plus coller de plus en plus
sous des veaux de ce col maintenant
impossible de bouger
impossible de les séparer et avec le 3
l'état ne bouge plus coincé dans cette
position peu importe ce qu'il se passait
tant que josé l'a pas le contraire mais
doit rester coincé collet est soudé
maintenant alors ceux et celles dont les
eaux sont encore coincées c'est que la
suggestion passe très bien le
subconscient de capte vous le sentez ici
non ça va aucun agile qui hélas ici et
ça fonctionne ici et francesca aussi ça
fonctionne il est déjà parti à dessein
dans un monde de rêve et d'imaginaire
alors attention et de rémy le bout des
doigts fixé le bout des doigts
gilles vous commencez à dormir
maintenant francs dormez dormez sentant
bg vous dormez initier votre place
dormez suivante à toi pourra sortir
mais c'est votre corps pour ne pas
tomber
gilles vous vous sentez merveilleusement
bien solide
maintenant vous êtes solide jusqu'à
regardez bien le bout des doigts
francesca tout matignon ou fermer les
yeux être lourde et pesante et je sais
faire vous commencez à dormir
dormez dormez avec l'a1 dormait avec le
2 et dormez vous vous sentez
merveilleusement bien
très détendu et relaxé dormez vous
sentez bien maintenant francesca et
gilamont signal de les apprendre à
bouger dans un monde de rêve et
d'imaginaire à mon signal vous allez
changer de posture avez vous imaginé
couché sur un dans votre salon assis
dans votre salon à relaxer sur une
chaise un peu inconfortable
vous allez tenter de trouver une posture
confortable 1 2 et 3a l'existence de
bouger à son confortable de vous
installer la nouvelle façon confortable
de vous installer allégé dans ce cadre
est sans cela draine gillon se redresse
francesca et quelques tout près d'où que
vous sentez dans votre bulle ça vous
énerve tout près d'oulan vous commencé à
lui parler à ces personnes dites lui de
de se déplacer vous voulez pas la vendre
à tout près de vous cette période bouge
pas réagit très bien c'est bon parfum
alors maintenant je les ai fait bouger
l'imaginaire est maintenant activé on
peut programmer leur subconscient réagir
à l'émission je m'approche de vous
francesca et détendue où l accès vous
gilles restez bien assis
concentrez-vous sur ma bois vous
entendez ma voix alors qu'est ce que tu
aimerais avoir de francesca par exemple
alors je n'ai rien que home ou chiens y
est d'accord homo jour ce serait bien
que robot chatons elle est persuadée que
bernard montiel est un chaton al qudra
le charisme je veux bien
alors attention ventures car à chaque
fois que tu vas entendre le mot chatons
ne pas penser que bernard est un chaton
et vallées le caresser alors attention
mais dans la viande bien sûr sur la tête
non non non non alors attention quand il
entendra le mot chatons ont pensé que
bernard est un chaton et tu allais le
caresser sur la tête sur le dos à la
tension et projet le maintenant je vais
maintenant comptant désormais à voir jj
j'aimerais bien alors fils on serait en
fait ce que j'aimerais c'est que homo
culture
gilles verdez il va se prendre pour
julien lepers et il posera des questions
ok d'accord alors attention aux anges il
n'entendra le mot culture
venez vous imaginez être julien lepers
il allait poser des questions comme lui
à sa façon attention danger ce cas et
gilles d'aller vous éveillez tour dans
un état d'hypnose vous allez réagir à
ces suggestions 1 2 et 3 on ouvrait les
yeux
manchester et gilles parfait alors on va
on va on va faire le 4 à la suite avec
julien lepers oui on va jouer avec nos
amis bien entendu qu'ils sont là sarah
francesca sarah gilles labeouf est très
bien là merci les plats on va jouer
quatre à la suite vous avez vu qu'elle
est julien lepers francesca vous avez vu
qu'ils avaient julien lepers
on va jouer quatre à la suite on va
jouer tous ensemble vous avez joué
également chez vous avec vous puisque
julien le quiz de julien lepers de
spectacle les téléspectateurs peuvent
gagner 1000 euros et bien ce soir les
téléspectateurs ont peut être gagné
également aux 6000 euros avec le 4 à la
suite alors sur twitter il ya un twittos
ce qui va gagner 1000 euros je vous le
dis est normal si vous arrivez à faire
quatre bonnes réponses il a su d'accord
d'accord
est ce que vous êtes prêt mentalement et
c'est parti c'est le 4ème
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gilbert des c'est ce que vous trouvez
qu'ils ont de la culture julien lepers
dans quel sport peut-on jouer piller
demi d'ouverture ou trois quarts les
demies oui oui oui
[Applaudissements]
les violets comment le désactiver ce
qu'on on peut pas le programmer pour un
autre truc est-ce qu'il peut pas devenir
ce qu on va on va pas pouvoir ça parce
qu'on peut pas faire un truc comme aux
bougies il se met à danser mais sans
censure entre monde en fait ok parfait
en fait il parlera il suivra la
conversation dans son jeu donnez moi la
main fermez les yeux crois qu'il a de la
culture lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui c'est très intense
alors attention gilles maintenant que
vous allez entendre le moule
vous allez entendre le mot bouger
d'aller vous lever et danser comme si de
rien n'était et répondent aux questions
comme si de rien n'était et quand vous
allez entendre le mot fini venez vous
éveillez vous allez cesser de bouger
retourner à votre place
attention aux mots bougez vous vous
levez et vous dansez et quand vous
entendez le mot fini vous allez vous
asseoir
attention tout va bien dans l'axé ou des
tombelles d'euros tout va très bien et
c'est intense inde alors mon chaton à
toi quel jour à tonnage at on sait cha
cha et ben tiens tiens tiens tiens
cherche un chien chien chat c'est pas
prévu dans mes chiens ces bonds à n'en
pas trop cher pour y retourner votre
bafa wisha c'est fini qu'est-ce que je
fais là là bas je sais pas artois comm
tba ce dernier c'est comme ça c'est
normal
merci francesca c'est beaucoup aimé
cette séquence pour l'instant on est à
trois la suite la mairie et suivez un
peu c'est ça peut jouer sur scène là
c'est sur ce qu'est ce qu'a question
attention pouvait gagner 1000 euros chez
vous si elle répondait à cette question
à lille où une chicha oui elle jours à
10h50
chaque jour à 10h50 que remue des
candidats devant thierry beccaro les
boules
ouais exactement ça gagne
le rapport vous et moi
franchement vous donne pas envie de
bouger dans ses folles comment l'aider
comment le décor comme en le désactivant
le désert
il faut dire fini fini fini merci